que non
oh
un
passant
[Musique]
claire flambeau du monde chanson tirée
de l'opéra ballet les indes galantes du
compositeur jean philippe rameau ce
matin-là cette classe de cm2 a pour
objectif de chanter en choeur et sans
fausse note ce titre baroque ou tous
ensemble et puis j'aime bien chanter et
peluches et à mesure les petits jeux qui
aiment s'y déploie se chauffer la fois
on tourne et ensuite à la fin on va
chanter une chanson polaire flocke du
monde c'est bien je vais bien le style
le style de l'eau 14 c j'aime bien la
musique c'est très relaxant je m'amuse
bien et c'est au rôle et on travaillait
très bien en vous le centre de musique
baroque de versailles a lancé un
partenariat avec la ville de maurepas
pour faire connaître aux plus jeunes la
musique baroque depuis septembre ces
élèves ont assisté à quatre ateliers de
chant mais aussi de conscience du corps
un parcours artistique complet cette
chanteuse lyrique nîmes le court ce que
c'est vraiment un bon début je trouve
que qui a beaucoup d'énergie qui a
beaucoup de plaisir à découvrir à leurs
voix ce que je trouve super à la danse
et qu'il découvre ça avec tout leur être
avec tout leur tout leur corps et il ya
une ouverture qui est formidable
beaucoup d'enfants ne connaissent pas
l'univers baroque le but pour le cmb et
les écoles accompagner et former les
élèves à la diversité des genres
musicaux le baroque l'île pour la
plupart sont bien connus que sanofi
devrait offrir
de la musique autre que celle qu'ils
écoutent à la maison ou entre copains et
donc
ça permet aussi d'avoir des repères de
repères dans la musique classique
qu'elle quel compositeur dans quel but
on écrivait tel ou tel morceau après
cette initiation les élèves qui
partiront au collège louis pergaud se
réuniront en section artistique dès la
5e au programme chants danses décors et
mise en scène
[Applaudissements]